bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france la situation est
telle que l'on craint donc on agite le
spectre d'une troisième vague une
troisième vague fatale même un selon
certains est ce qu'il y en aura une de
troisième vague vous pensez c'est
toujours difficile de prévoir l'avenir
comme on le dit depuis le début
pour le moment il ya des cas qui
arrivent il ya des cas positifs on est
très très loin de la congestion des
services et je ne vois pas pourquoi il
faut s'agiter s'alarmer forcément à
l'avance si on regarde les chiffres de
la mortalité durant l'automne
alan surmortalité on est tout à fait
comparable sur des épisodes de grippaux
qui passait inaperçu avant donc il faut
être prudent et vigilant mais je ne sais
pas ce n'est pas la peine d'aller
affoler les personnes et là aussi quand
on parle confinement couvre-feu en
automne il ya eu des expériences dans
certains départements qui ont des
couvre-feux d'autres non je pense qu'il
faudrait peut-être analyser ces données
pour voir si ses mesures sociales ont un
vrai effet alors justement sur l'effet
des mesures sociales des mesures de
restrictions sanitaires il ya beaucoup
de questions de grogne aussi en tout cas
ce qui ressort même s'il vous dit qu'il
ne faut pas s'alarmer c'est qu'on a
quand même du mal à faire reculer cette
épidémie puisqu'on est sous le coup de
mesures sanitaires renforcés avec un
couvre-feu à 18 heures là encore
certains affirment que ces mesures de
restrictions elles ne vont pas assez
loin
on a eu les mesures de restriction de
couvre-feu en automne un confinement et
pendre en plein milieu du confinement
effectivement le nombre de cas
d'hospitalisation est resté constant et
en à peu près sur sa constance depuis
donc bien sûr que j'aimerais avoir la
solution pour que saab est mais il n'y a
pas de solution magique mais en tous les
cas ce n'est pas les confinements et les
couvre feux qui ont l'air d'être la
solution magique et vu la souffrance que
ça entraîne il faut réfléchir là dessus
moi ce que je reproche c'est qu'on a le
mélange politique et médecine qui font
mauvais ménage
en tout cas on évoque aussi un possible
troisième confinement le confinement
quand même ça semble efficace pour
lutter contre l'épidémie on l'a vu
notamment au plus fort de la crise
sanitaire c'était au mois d'avril
dernier mais on va dire là dessus je ne
suis pas du tout convaincu que ce
confinement est été la cause de l'arrêt
les épidémies vous avez vu ça fait des
vagues
on va dire et un système de gaussienne
ça va ça vient là on voit qu'on a peut
donc c'est ce qui s'est passé au mois
d'avril l'épidémie est venue et repartie
et c'est ce qu'on dit depuis le début
c'est que maintenant on voit qu'on a des
épidémies de vin rien et qui n'ont rien
à voir avec le confinement ou pas le
confinement sert qu'à chaque fois on
voit qu'on a des re départ parce que
c'est peut-être d'autres variant en tous
les cas le confinement n'a pas montré
son efficacité et je pense que la
démonstration la plus forte c'est pour
l'automne uni le couvre-feu dans les
départements avec ou sans couvre feu
nous ont montré leur efficacité ou leurs
différences et en plein milieu du
confinement
le nombre de baisses de contamination a
stagné
il n'a pas vraiment repris non plus à la
fin du confinement
donc je pense que ces mesures sont
inutiles ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que derrière les vétérinaires qui
ont l'habitude de gérer des crises
épidémique dans les élevages
il ne confirme pas leurs animaux
ensemble ça ne marche pas on isole les
animaux malades pour les soigner nous on
a une approche qui est complètement
différente de bloquer les gens les gens
peuvent se contaminer à la maison cette
semaine j'étais à paris dans les
transports en commun qui était bondé
voilà on va dire les gens c'est
difficile d'arrêter une épidémie et
c'est illusoire de croire qu'en laissant
les gens plus longtemps à la maison que
ça va stopper vous faisiez la seule
mesure oui elle est la seule mesure que
je rock et cacité finalement eux c'est
les déplacements on voit que justement
au printemps on a bloqué les
déplacements et l'épidémie n'a pas été
dans certaines régions ça c'est une
mesure qui me semble efficace
par contre de bloquer les gens la maison
qui vont travailler qui prennent les
transports en commun évidemment ils
contaminent de leur famille chez eux
vous faisiez allusion en variant du
virus ça c'est une grosse inquiétude
injustement
c'est une inquiétude justifiée ou il
faut pas céder à la panique et qu'est ce
qui peut nous attendre
ces prochaines semaines concernant ce
variant qui évoluent sur le territoire
français qui est déjà bien avancé
ailleurs en europe
déjà on va dire ça c'est la nature du
virus
quand on m'a dit que le virus mute et on
a été un peu raillé un entretien avec
eric chabrière professeur de biochimie
ali a chu de marseille